okay
hi everyone
today I'm going to talk about a recent
work with Sagar Patel and samita of the
journey who about responsibility of
reinforcement learning agents in for
systems applications
over the summer in this basically
results of his in terms
foreign
ly we see a lot of papers that show
success of reinforcement learning agent
in governing different system tasks
so examples of such applications are
adapted video streaming nsdn Network
optimization
um
faster job scheduling and in all these
papers it has been shown that if you
replace some
um maybe manually designed or
um what traditionally use heuristics for
certain processes with reinforcement a
lawn need agent then you will see
significant Improvement
in fact between where we uh also see the
same kind of a trend uh there are a lot
of minorities and heuristics that are
kind of hard coded and now very hard to
parse and there was a Pros that if we
really we also don't understand what's
going on there maybe we should try
reinforcement learning and see whether
we can get a good Agent to replace this
manual design heuristics
um however when it comes to real
deployment uh it's often um there is a
need from the user uh to understand what
um what this controller is doing because
controller is a black box right it's a
neural network and there was all um
people concerns about what the neural
networks are doing is good to provide
the user with some means of some tools
that um they can play uh with these
controllers and try to understand uh
what what is going on and it also build
up Trust
on the user side to trust your control
that it doesn't send sensible things
so okay background we are working with a
standard extended reinforcement learning
group when we have an agent that follows
some policy it takes uh observation as
an input to produce an action
this action goes into environment
and the environment uh taking
observation action move to the next
state of the system and also produces a
reward
so as I mentioned before we kind of
targeting systems uh applications and as
our running example we'll be using
adaptive bitrate streaming problem
it's a very simple problem you have a
server and you have a client and server
streams videos to the client
the video is streamed in chunks yeah
it's visualization of it so you every
time at every time point you have to
send one chunk of the video but also
depending on the network conditions you
can send this video and then give on a
different quote so you might have like a
low quality video medium quality video
maybe high quality video so at each time
point you have to decide what kind of
quality you use for the next chunk
so how um this problem is kind of
mapping to the standard Loop so our
observations will be
um history of
of the network how Network behaves and
how video player behaves our actions or
action of the controller is to pick what
quality of the video chunk will be next
and uh environment
um when we give a state and our decision
it outputs a reward and reward in this
case captures
foreign
how would the experience of the user in
watching this video
it's a composed reward I'll talk about
it later but overall It capture capture
a quality of the experience
right okay so now I'll talk about two uh
special properties that at least we've
identified in systems applications that
are somewhat different from standard
standard reinforcement learning group
first of all we don't have a model of
the environment what we have is a traces
traces it's uh
usually it's a real world traces that
actually capture uncertainty of the
environment
so here some examples to make it more
clear for example
um
adaptive bit rate control problem uh
Trace would represent throughput over
time right so and throughput actually
for this application capture uh external
condition capture uncertainty
in other applications can be a resource
demand over time load over time or
incoming jobs over time so this is a
trace that we are given usually they are
publicly available and what environment
is doing it just replaces traces right
so we don't have any model we have the
stresses recorded somewhere
um on real clusters so on the real
steaming platform and this just replay
replay environment just replaces traces
uh and this has environment environment
is model and traces are actually quite
tricky like in the case of throughput
you have favorable like very good
Network conditions you have bad Network
conditions so the traces a distribution
varies a lot
um another special properties that we
will be using is
um regarding the reward function so in
this applications reward function
capture quote of the experience so how
how well the system performs and usually
it's designed by the designer who has
very good understanding of the domain
knowledge so
um it means that a reward is a usually a
linear combination of some important
performance characteristics of your
system in case of
in case of adaptive to trick for example
we have a linear combination of three
performance characteristic quality of
the video so you want to send it's a
positive contributional kind of a
positive reward because you want as high
quality as better for the for the client
you don't want to see a lot of policy
change you don't want to see
um that client yes one channel
considering a very high qualities and
very low quality jumps all the time so
it's not a very good experience and the
worst thing that can happen at least in
this settings is stolen when no video
took place uh client just has
interrupted experience so you really
don't want it to you penalize and
similar compost reward you can see in
other applications like condition
control and age questions
right to summarize there are these two
properties that will be exploited for
our responsibility results so that we
have this traces and importantly that
they are publicly available so you can
always have access to them and we will
also exploit that the reward uh
functions are decomposable and each
component of the reward function is mean
right so to convince you that the rise
is publicly available cases for example
for adaptive Retreat control you can go
to the uh this platform it's called
puffer it's run by Stanford for uh for
streaming videos to clients and they use
there are tons of tons of data you can
go there and just collect it that's what
we did first
and you can even train your controller
and trans and see how it performs so
it's a live system
every day it collects traces they're
publicly available so anyone can go and
try
right so now we'll talk about
explainability
so uh
explainability as I said it's originated
with our discussion with various product
groups that we do need some form of
explainability but before we start
working with vulnerability is a tough
question what is explainability what how
we are going to explain what is a unit
of explanation on top of it there are
multiple assumptions that you have to
make like do you know the model is it a
black box it's a white box so we did
have to do multiple decisions so we
decided that we'll be working in Black
Box settings so we don't know
internals of the policy for us it's a
black box Network so we are going to the
Black Box settings and what we are going
to explain we want to explain the action
we want to explain why at current state
was controller decides to take action
aod
now uh the next question is how we are
going to explain it right what is the
unit of explanation what do we give the
user as an explanation again there are
multiple things here you can explain the
action looking at the current state but
we decided to do a different thing we we
decided to do the explanation uh by
looking in the future so
conceptually we want to give the user
understanding or what if you take action
a what are the future consequences or if
you take action B what is the future
consequences in this way first of all we
provide the user with some understanding
what's going on what is the consequences
of taking certain actions and if you
have two actions you can actually
compare and and kind of see one one y
action was better than the other
so how it will look like oh wait
right so how it will look like let's say
we will have our explainer and we have
uh one action given the same state we
have two actions I will be sent a low
quality video or high quality video and
explainer will kind of summarize future
consequences of this action so what are
the future consequences of sending uh
low quality chunk or future consequences
or sending high quality chunks
um
I think yes it's fine um and um okay yes
is the following two
to
to give a user explanation we use we
summarize future in our decomposed
reward components remember that there
was emphasizing that each word component
has a mean
so what will give is the user will give
a
expectation causing each reward
component will evolve when they take a
certain action
and for that we need to
um
obtains this quantities we need to learn
the predictor right that given a state
in the action uh it outputs what does
what is the expected value for this
reward component over time in the
looking into the future
so How We Do It
um remember that they said that uh we
assume that Trace is a publicly
available so somewhere we can get them
we have no assumptions on the controller
so it's a black box for us Now with uh
to to just explaining our first step is
to um transfer the problem of building
responsibility to supervise learning
problem so we take a stresses and we
take a controller which is a black box
and we run it and they collect data so
you and the state and the action we
collect the rewards over a certain
period of time but not just a reward but
remember this decomposed reward so
reward component for the quality for
Quality change and for the stalling we
collected a certain over a period of
time and we wait them
so for each state in the action we
collect this quantity
it's expected to return for the quality
expected return for the quality change
and the expected return for the stoning
and now we have a supervised learning
problem right so we run this policy and
environment quite a while and now we
have just a data set observation or
state action and what is the future
consequences of this app and we just
have a data set and then from that we
can learn the predictor so it's just a
surprise learning problem retaining the
neural network which has quite
complicated architecture but anyway then
it's just a neural network and this is
our explainer
so now
um few important properties at least we
like about our explainer so we don't all
the previous work uh not all but many
many papers that were looking at similar
type of
um questions they were altering the
training group so they were interfering
the training procedure so we don't have
any knowledge of the training procedure
we don't care what it was we just have a
controller to work with we don't have
any assumptions about about the policy
because we just call it right and our
cost for the flash is very low because
it's just a neural network again so you
have a you will give me a your state
your action and that will give you
consequences of this action
right so this is how it will look for
the for the user at least in the basic
form again
um we have our explainer now we will
learn it we have two actions low quality
video high quality video and what we
will return to the user uh expected
um or returns for each of the components
of the reward function so how we expect
a quality variable of a certain bounded
Horizon of course how uh quality change
will evolve of a bounded Horizon and how
stolen and we do it for both actions and
then just visually a user might be able
to compare and make sense of it of
course there are questions like how to
make sense of it but even with these
simple settings it's already in some
cases yeah I'm almost
right so uh I'll show the results we run
it on two
um
systems adaptive betrayed I was using as
a running example and condition control
just to give you an example
um let's say you have this adaptive
control system and you have two actions
A and B right and maybe uh you
unexpectedly uh for you control drops
the quality of the weekend you're
wondering why is it controllable drop
the quality of the idea shouldn't send
the high quality because it's better for
us and uh just uh what I'll explain the
returns it says okay if you take action
a you cover some quality videos just
numbers right so you you will pay for
the quality change you have a drop on
the quality video but you will have no
stalling but if you keep sending let's
say action with a high quality video
then if you keep sending uh in the high
quality of chunks and you will
experience Stollings it has a highest
penalty so you really don't want it yeah
okay so just we show that for then what
what's important to estimate this
um numbers correctly and we show that we
do it better than Baseline and yeah so
this in summary we propose this
framework for example ability of
reinforcement planning controls where we
are targeting systems applications and
we use this to examples adaptively
trading condition control and the future
workers to see what they can apply to
other systems
that's it I think the end of my talk
thank you
[Applause]
okay
good question while the next Speaker
gets you can set up
thank you for the great talk I was
wondering what exactly goes into your
observations of the state like are you
sort of considering also the historical
um
so it's actually depends on the control
in many of them yeah you still have
about the teacher okay
the buffer size for the adapter that's
historical information but we are trying
to
okay
[Music]
foreign
title is generating adversarial examples
and defense methods for online fraud
detection